joe biden has selected for his running
mate one of the least likable people in
america kamala harris who was booted out
of the democratic presidential primary
early on because nobody wants her
to be in the white house but joe biden
insisted he had to pick a black woman
who's liberal who's a democrat
there are a number of women of color
latino women
asian across the board so he he narrowed
his
options all in the name of diversity of
course and he wasn't able to pick
karen bass who is a communist or susan
rice who was the fall man for benghazi
so that left
that left kamala harris big day big win
for kamala harris
how is she reacting well here's the big
announcement video
all right
hi hi hi hi sorry to keep you that's all
right
[Music]
you ready to go to work
[Music]
oh my god i'm so ready to go to work
i was raised to take action my mother
knew that she was raising two black
daughters who would be treated
differently
because of how they looked stop pause it
right there there it is
there it is oh poor kamala the victim
of oppression grew up as a black child
in america
and she's just so darn oppressed except
except kamala harris actually does not
descend from any american
slaves her mother's indian her father's
jamaican and
unbelievably her jamaican father wrote
an essay in which he explained
that kamala descends not from slaves in
america
but from a jamaican slave owner
now i don't think she needs to include
that in her pitch i don't think she
needs to say
i was born in a lineage of oppressors
and slave owners i don't think you have
to say that but likewise
to pretend that she's this great victim
of oppression in her life
manifestly untrue she goes on
whenever i got upset about something my
mother would look me in the eye and ask
so what are you going to do about it
that's why
when i saw a broken justice system i
became a lawyer
to try and fix it that's why during this
that's why when i saw a broken justice
system that was
incarcerating a lot of young black men i
i decided to do my part
and become a prosecutor and throw way
more young black men in prison
this vibe sounds like yoga
see she just oh she's so awful this is
why nobody
on the left or the right likes her or
wants her to hold elective office
she's trying to have it both ways
earlier on in her career she was tough
on crime
i think that's good i think you should
be tough on crime i don't i don't
remember
her describing the criminal justice
system as racist then
i don't remember her people calling her
racist or anything for for being tough
on crime
but now that the the whole political
left is against the cops and wants to
let all the criminals out of prison now
all of a sudden the criminal justice
system
is racist so which is it you have to
pick a lame you can't simultaneously be
the person who is really tough on crime
and then the person who says that if we
ever enforce our laws that somehow
that's racist and she's going to fix it
once again speaking out of both sides of
her mouth have you ever smoked
i have okay and i and i inhaled i didn't
i did it
[Laughter]
during the foreclosure crisis i took on
the big banks
as california's attorney general it's
why as
united states senator i have fought to
represent people
like my mother people who politicians
often overlook
or don't take seriously right now
america needs action in the middle of a
pandemic
the president is trying to rip away
health care while small businesses close
he's given breaks to his wealthy donors
and when the people cried out for
support he teargassed them america is in
crisis
and i know joe biden will lead us out of
it
he's a man of faith decency god paul's
suppose he's a man of faith he's so
deeply catholic that he supports
abortion on demand paid for by taxpayers
because he's
he's so catholic joe biden he's such a
man of deep faith that when he was
serving as vice president
his administration tried to litigate a
group of nuns into the dirt because they
wouldn't pay for abortion pills oh what
a
man of d he's such a man of deep faith
that he was denied the eucharist by a
priest
because he's clearly an apostate who is
publicly brazenly in a state of grave
mortal sin
a man of deep faith joe biden
supported by kamala harris another woman
whose convictions i'm sure
run so so deep i did it
he raised his family that way i saw it
firsthand with my good friend
bo as joe says we're in a battle
so we mentioned beau we're not going to
mention the other
the sort of you know the 300 pound
drug-addled adulterous
corrupt china and ukraine money take an
elephant in the room we're not going to
talk about hunter no i guess probably
hunter's not going to make it into
the commercial battle for the soul of
this nation
but together it's a battle we can win
we just have to take action first of all
is the answer yes
the answer is absolutely yes joe and i
am ready to work
i am ready to do this with you for you i
i just i'm just deeply honored and i'm
very
excited wow kamala is almost as
articulate as joe i'm just yes yes
justin justin yes i wanna yes yes take
action so
the parts of i i basically divvy this
into three parts
one is some bogus claim of oppression
based on completely misrepresenting her
biography
and her experience in america so deeply
oppressed that she's been at very high
levels of government her entire life
and and now is is a running mate and
could be the vice president so oppressed
and that little girl
was me that's the first part the next
part is just is just
lies about donald trump what lies about
the trump administration you know the
tear gassing the peaceful protesters and
all this
nonsense and then the third part and i
think this is the most important part
are just vacuous platitudes
racism is
bad we have to do something we got to
take
action okay what kind of action do you
want to take what do you want to do
because you and joe for that matter your
whole career is you
you want to do this and then when the
political winds blow another way you
want to do
the other thing even she goes i want to
represent people like my mother who
aren't represent
how is your mother not represented and
what what is people like your mother
what are you referring to
i mean these people are so obsessed with
race and sex maybe she means indians or
or women or something like that but but
even so what does that say what does
that mean
people like them you know when president
trump ran in 2016 he said i want to
represent the forgotten people of
america who's he talking about
people in the so-called flyover country
people who had manufacturing jobs
people who don't participate in a
globalized elite people who don't work
for finance or
international law or banking or
something like consulting something like
that right
people who don't necessarily go to the
fanciest schools that's who he was
who is kamala talking about nobody no
it's nothing it's just air it's just hot
air coming out
and two empty suits joe biden and now
empty pantsuit kamala harris i don't
think he could have made a more fitting
[Music]
[Music]
choice
you